you know yesterday i showed you a video
of a 92 year old holocaust survivor who
survived auschwitz that was really the
most brutal of all the concentration
camps um
and talking about how this stuff
the creeping side of authoritarianism
how it happens incrementally first you
sort of talk about those people in that
certain way those people are diseased
those people are dirty those people are
greedy those people are evil then you
say those people shouldn't be on those
benches because there's other benches
they can be on and they shouldn't be at
our schools because they can have their
own schools and they shouldn't go on
these buses and they shouldn't go into
these theaters maybe they shouldn't shop
at the same hours as often us and the
series of things that happen slowly
because now it's very strange what's
happened to all of us in the last two
years if you would have asked most
people two years ago like how did the
nazis come to power how could something
so obviously evil
come to power
most people really wouldn't know you
wouldn't really understand yeah you
could read it in a textbook and you
could go oh there was this guy hitler
and he was this really great speaker and
germany was really upset after world war
one and they were economically depressed
and they needed a scapegoat and you can
sort of intellectualize it at some level
but how does that
get you to oh we're going to exterminate
six million of our people we're going to
launch a war and millions and millions
of russians are going to be killed and
we're going to rampage across europe and
all of those things and how do you turn
citizen against citizen and make people
that were neighbors next thing you know
literally shooting their neighbors and
having them dig their own ditches and
all the
extraordinary horrors that are almost
too crazy to mention right has it
happened well i think if you asked most
people two years ago they would have
given you some intellectual version of
it where in the last two years i think
we all kind of see it at this point you
can kind of see it you can kind of see
how for two years you would demonize
demonize
those people shouldn't go on planes
happening in canada right now those
people shouldn't go on trains happening
in canada right now those people should
be put in quarantine camps special camps
for them happening in australia right
now
those people shouldn't be able to go
into certain stores without showing
their papers happening in new york city
right now happening in los angeles right
now so the slow creep of these things
is i think showing us something very
very evil but
very important to know about human
nature anyway yesterday i saw a clip of
jordan peterson on joe rogan's show this
is from about four years ago so this is
before
uh obviously before covid and all that
before lockdowns before masks and all
that it's also right at the beginning of
when jordan was sort of catching on and
one of the things that i find so
interesting about it is is when you see
someone from years ago that was talking
about things that are now so relevant so
with all that in mind uh here's a quick
clip of jordan talking about the warning
signs and how things can get much worse
before you even know things get to
terrible places one tiny step at a time
you know if i encroach i if i encroach
on you and i'm sophisticated about it
i'm going to encroach two millimeters
i'm going to encroach right to the point
where you stop start to protest then i'm
gonna stop then i'm gonna wait
then you're gonna calm down then i'm
gonna encroach again right to the point
where you protest then i'm gonna stop
then i'm gonna wait and i'm just gonna
do that forever and before you know it
you're gonna be back three miles from
where you started and you'll have done
it one step at a time and then you'll go
oh how'd i get here and the answer was
well
i pushed you a little farther than you
should have gone and you agreed and so
then i pushed you a little farther than
you should have gone again and you
agreed and if anybody's interested in
this sort of process and this is a
horrifying book if you want to read
about how this process works you can
read a book called ordinary men by
robert browning i actually ordered
ordinary men last night so i will read
the book and and hopefully i can
share some more of those ideas with you
but does that sound
familiar does that kind of sound like
what's happening right now
do you think history repeats itself do
you think human nature is what it is and
nazis just don't miraculously show up
like that do you think you slowly
dehumanize people do you think you
slowly otherwise people and next thing
you know good people are doing horrible
things
good people are ratting on their
neighbors good people are assaulting
people because they're not wearing masks
etc etc could it all actually be
happening right now
i don't know what do you think let me
know